I can't wait to see one of you show up
to College GameDay with a sign that says
Campins crimson corner you hillbillies
checks out that's what he said ask him
if you know the hometown and hillbilly
one of his star students is none other
than head coach Kyle would enhance Chloe
he's mad at coach Kidman
looks like there are some arguments
doing yourself in lane on the sidelines
or at least there's no arguments those
are called ash toons I mean if you need
to scold your offensive coordinator
after a thirty point win you need to
re-examine your life it's been two years
since we've checked in on Alabama's
number one public access call-in show
and since then old lane is traded in his
wedding ring for a championship ring it
turns out he's as mad at me and a
husband as he has being a head coach
we're back again with triple K you'll
notice a little addition to the trophy
case this time also thanks to my lovely
now ex-wife for being here and letting
me use my old phone let's take some
calls hi coach it's Sarah from the bar
and then the back of that uber and then
the cot in your office last night
anyway you left one of your father's at
my place and you still owe me for your
half of the morning-after pill sorry
about that guys
lynly just need to blow off a little
steam next caller like all your stuff
got destroyed I guess now you know how
it feels to be a player trying to
transfer out of your dirty program you
patty backstabbing keep it laid it
simple next caller hey coach this is
more of an X's and O's question if I
bang your ex-wife you think I'll see her
old face I pray the next tornado
finishes you off bricks late at the dumb
name next caller you're down on Lane
Street play your buddy Steve Sarkisian
hey sark
sound a little intoxicated you know
you're not supposed to be drinking right
shut out the band before hiring the
pac-12 sloppy seconds you can roll tide
hey speaking of sloppy seconds how about
that hot blonde power sex you couldn't
keep happy I want to pee on you Leila
he's just tired the lane is leaving the
station next caller congratulations on
your raise coach thank you you mean our
rings you gonna use that as hush money
for the college she knock up or
just blow it all getting your asshole
bleached you effeminate West Coast twink
nice khakis fruit I got a question about
fall control why can't you control your
balls and stop trying to carry buck
tooth wipe our horeb a me go doc Wayne I
was wondering are there any actual plays
on that card for do you just use it to
hide your doughy baby face you cocky go
Buckeyes
what's been your biggest challenge at
Alabama Justin SEC defenses or
convincing college girls or
41 year old undergrad named Joey
freshwater go fails a head coach in the
big ten queer Trump 2016
reel callers out there hey Lane you miss
being a head coach or do you prefer the
excitement of saving yelling at you like
a child on national TV all right we'll
French kiss your dad for me dick face
good question what feels better when
Nick Saban chews out your asshole or
when his daughter fingers it I will find
yourself an oncoming traffic you
traitorous come on guys can we please
try to clean it up nice tits bitch
always good to hear from one of our
regular callers hey while you're up why
don't you hang yourself with that too
long phone cord run another bubble
screen you unoriginal
I was wondering just boosters give money
with the understanding that you'll
they're gross wives so they don't have
to don't even stay in your lane hyaline
jerry jones here finally fired jason
garrett i want to make you the next head
coach of the Cowboys how quick can you
get to Dallas oh thank you mr. Jones I'm
already past this is perfect just
kidding it's me Sark again bartender
dark oak to go please hey but seriously
I heard they're replacing me with less
mouth you didn't hear that from me say
what you will about his morals the man
is still gorgeous to look at
[Music]
you